brody hier lors d'une conférence de
presse par les partenaires sociaux comme
étant la cause de tous leurs malheurs
le règlement intérieur de mosaïque est
devenu après quatre jours le des motifs
d'un mouvement d'humeur qui semble être
au départ lié au licenciement d'une
salariée déception de da pour dix
salariés qui n'est pas signé il évalue
on n'est pas content au règlement
intérieur sont venus s'ajouter d'autres
boutiques de crispation aussi variés que
la vétusté des véhicules ou des injures
vers les agents ils sont largement
exprimés dans ce courrier reçu le 11
novembre par la direction des motifs qui
ont entraîné le droit de retrait des
salariés mais ces raisons évoquées
justifie t elle réellement le droit de
retrait le droit de retrait c'est le
droit qu'a le salarié de se retirer
d'arrêter son travail lorsqu'il estime
lorsqu'ils jugent qu'il y à un danger
grave et imminent
la cour de cassation la direction
française indique que les juges
d'apprécier au cas par cas
donc il n'ya pas de règle en fin de
quart où on exclut totalement le droit
de retrait il ya simplement des règles
des conditions pour que notre 13,3 soit
exercée et le juge va apprécier au cas
par cas si les conditions sourire le
droit de retrait des agents entre une et
cinq jours d'arrêt sur le risoux
l'origine de cette paralysie était au
départ lié à une procédure de
licenciement pour propos injurieux
ce motif contesté par certains
syndicalistes peut-il dans d'autres cas
entre nuls licenciement bien évidemment
salarié peut être licencié pour des
propos injurieux il faudra vérifier dans
quelles circonstances ces propos ont été
prononcés
est-ce qu'ils ont été prononcés en
présence de clients en présence de
supérieurs hiérarchiques
est ce que le salarié avait des raisons
d'être énervé d'être mécontents le juge
va apprécier toutes les circonstances
qui entourent cette insulte un
licenciement pour propos injurieux puis
une plate forme de revendications qui
s'étoffe de vieux démons ressurgissent
qui dirige vraiment le réseau mozaik à
qui profite la paralysie soudaine du
tcsp qui entre à peine dans les
habitudes des martiniquais le silence
des autorités surprend en attendant les
usagers prennent leur mal en patience
mais pour combien de temps